was a double overtime victory was not a
well-played game it was it's not going
in the Naismith Hall of Fame it was the
ultimate non clutch game meantime the
Timberwolves they win the opening tip
and they're going to not even possess
the basketball they're gonna just let
the shot clock run out I would guess now
and it's right at the spot where Kobe
Bryant passed my clitoris
so Andrew gets the honor of putting it
down where Kobe Bryant scored those two
free-throws days and you've not a shot
clock violation they don't advance the
ball so an eight-second violation
exactly so teams doing an homage to Kobe
in both ways with the eight-second
violation as well as the 24-second
violation and now the Kings will return
the favor and let the shot clock run out
in 24 seconds is the crowd applauding
the gesture by both teams
it's a great moment great tribute again
putting it back down where Kobe passed
MJ on that memorable night back in 2014
Luke Walton a great teammate and won
championships with Kobe Bryant it was a
really difficult day for him now of all
the people in this building Jimmy be
hard-pressed to find anybody who is more